la parole est maintenant notre collègue
françois baroin pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
alors où nous nous adressons à travers
ces questions d'actualité au sénat
un homme un policier de 36 ans est entre
la vie et la mort il a payé dans est
déjà lui sa famille ses collègues de la
bac
l'ensemble des collègues policiers
gendarmes et forces de l'ordre sur notre
territoire un lourd tribut les médecins
annoncent un cas de détresse vitale
qu'il me soit permis au nom du groupe
auquel j'appartiens et au nom duquel je
m'exprime les républicains à l'instar de
la représentation nationale d'adressé
nous posséder plus émue à sa famille à
ses proches à ses collègues
ainsi à travers ce message qu'à
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre sur
notre territoire qui dans un contexte de
terrorisme développer
matin midi et soir s'efforce de garantir
la sécurité de nos compatriotes nous
avons appris mais je vais vous demander
de nous confirmer que le meurtrier
faisait l'objet d'une surveillance d'une
fiche classé s ce qui n'est pas une
classification parmi d'autres c'est au
titre la sûreté de l'état
je vous demande donc monsieur prémices
de nous confirmer dans un premier temps
qu'il y avait bien une fiche s sur cet
individu
nous avons appris qu'il avait obtenu une
permission de sortie qu'il n'était pas
rentré
cette permission de sortie était le 27
mai plusieurs mois se sont écoulés
nous avons appris que cet individu avec
un casier judiciaire long comme le bras
faisait l'objet d'une surveillance s
mais pour des relations avec une
mouvance islamiste
le confirmez-vous j'ai trois questions
très simples la première comment
fonctionnent les services de la dgsi
avec les juges d'application des peines
pour qu'un individu de sa nature
surveiller à ce titre là puissent sortir
la deuxième quelles mesures comptez vous
prendre pour que l'incompréhension et la
colère qui monte dans le pays sur cette
affaire puisse être apaisé pour vous
répondre
la parole à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le sénateur
françois baroin je me suis rendu hier
après midi auprès des policiers de saint
denis pour exprimer ma solidarité et ma
tristesse et être auprès d'eux comme
j'ai essayé d'être auprès d'eux avec le
premier ministre
lorsque des policiers du service de
protection des personnalités sont tombés
au mois de janvier ou lorsque un
policier ahmed mera b avait trouvé la
mort après que des barbares la veille
abattu froidement parce que cette
solidarité elle est normale et elle est
un devoir d'état que s'est il passé
précisément un individu qui était en
prison a été dans des conditions qu'a
précisé la garde des sceaux tout à
l'heure et dans le cadre des
dispositions législatives en vigueur a
bénéficié à bénéficier d'une d'une
possibilité d'accomplir les formalités
après le décès de son père moi je n'ai
pas à me prononcer sur une décision qui
a été prise par un juge parce que les
opérations des pouvoirs existent et
qu'ils y compris lorsqu'il ya de
l'émotion
et lorsqu'il ya des drames les principes
de droit doivent être appliquées après
que 7e après que cette évasion a eu lieu
l'individu a été signalé comme étant
radicaliser c'est à ce moment là qu'une
fiche s a été établi le concernant et
seulement après et pas avant et
l'affichent s il était normal qu'elle
soit établie
de la même manière qu'il était normal
qu'ils soient inscrits au fichier des
personnes recherchées
parce que c'était un élément
indispensable à sa récupération imaginer
qu'il ait franchi le territoire national
il était normal qu'on procède à cette
inscription
parce que c'était la condition pour que
l'affiché s
sonne et qu'on puisse le récupérer à
partir du moment où cet événement s'est
produit
l'ensemble des services de l'état se
sont mobilisés pour procéder aux conclut
libération et ce sont les services de
police hier qu'ils ont payé un lourd
tribut en procédant à la neutralisation
de cet individu qui était un individu
extrêmement dangereux et je veux rendre
hommage aux policiers qu en dix ans qui
dans ces circonstances ont fait un
travail absolument remarquable et qui
mérite toute notre considération